ah let's start them so today so last
time we introduced Bell's Theorem now we
all know what Bell's Theorem is saying
and have some idea of its of this kind
of sweep of ideas that's led to where we
are now and then such as plays such a
central role in quantum information in
fact today I want to look at the same
kind of parrot quasi paradoxical
situations borders of paradox situations
arising in contextuality from a
different perspective and to show that
there is topology they're really quite
close to the surface I'm not going to go
into full depth in that I'll mentions if
you are interested in assuming that
strand I'll mention some things that
come out of it but the nice thing is
we'll really be able to see the
topological structure because these sort
of examples are relatively small and
highly visualizable and we'll see that
there are connections with quite classic
topics in in in logic in the study of
paradoxes and also in some issues that
are of arise in contemporary model
theory as well and then I'm going having
you know we've been looking at examples
but then what I'll do in the latter part
of the lecture is introduce a general
setting where we can look at a wide
really an adequately wide range of
examples uniform way and we'll be using
that for the remainder of the of the
lectures so let me sort of briefly
review some of what we said at the end
of yesterday's lecture so observables on
the realist
point of view are reflecting objective
properties of a physical system
independent of our choice of which
measurements to perform and what that
saying is that for each possible state
of a system there's a function which
tells you what the value of each
measurement that you could perform on
the system would be
independently of which other
measurements may be performed and this
is the point of view is called non
contextuality and it's really equivalent
to the assumption of a classical source
we don't have to believe that the world
is deterministic but we do have to
believe that it's determinate so what I
mean is that the what what the lambda is
could itself be chosen according to some
probability distribution there could it
be a stochastic process driving what we
see but the what this the space over
which this stochastic process ranges is
globally assigning well-defined values
to all the variables that we could
measure so this is the idea of non of
non canonical textuality
it's this view which is impossible to
sustain in the light of our actual
observations of reality at the
microscopic level and this is what we
were discussing yesterday and the
impressive experiments that have now
been performed so here's the sort of a
picture essentially relating to the
exposition by David Berman from some
twenty years ago so we think of the the
source as generating the these want
Mirman called instruction sets thus the
values for all the measurements that we
might be performing of course they could
be you know infinitely many measurements
but here we're we only we can already
witness these phenomena with finitely
many measurements and finitely many
possible values of the measurements
everything works in a very finite rewai
and we have Alice and Bob here and there
they're performing their measurements
and this would be the picture if the non
contextual view held sway and the point
is that we know that it doesn't so here
is one of the examples we discussed last
time it's you it is usually called the
Hardy paradox so again we see the term
paradox being used and the point of this
introduced by Lucien Harvey 1992 was to
have a form of Bell's Theorem without
probabilities so we our original
derivation
following the style of bell and and the
people who came afterwards in particular
the it's often coupled with ch SH
Clouzot horn shamone Ian Holt who really
introduced the typical inequality that's
that's the most widely used but we saw
that that was an inequality based on the
quantitative information coming from
probabilities and we saw in our
discussion of Hardy's paradox last time
that we could make the argument that
there must be that there can't be a
classical source by showing that a bell
in equality must be violated even
without knowing what the probabilities
are just from knowing the support and
now I want to take this a step further
and say that we can make a direct
argument at the logical level that
doesn't go by way of an inequality and
actually now not only do we only need
the support we don't even need all 16
entries we only need four if we have
these four that's sufficient to show
that there can't be a classical source
so this is really the minimum that we
need for the argument so let's just be
clear about what these things are saying
it's the same Alice Bob arrangement here
of for the settings here are the
possible outcomes and this is saying
that the probability of getting this
joint out transfer these measurements is
in the support so it has a positive
probability whereas these are not in the
support so they have probability 0 in
other words these are impossible this is
possible so we're speaking at the level
of possibilities and that's all we need
in order to make the argument now let's
say there was a classical source a
probability distribution over
instruction sets which generated a table
like this generated a more detailed
table which we could project down to
this information what would it have to
do well they would since this thing is
possible there must be some instruction
set in the support of that classical
source distribution which would which
will have positive probability there
must be some lambda which which which is
possible according to the classical
source so what could this lambda be well
we know what it has to assign to these
two variables it has to assign zero to
both of them because this thing is in
the support what values does it assign
to the other variables and this is the
point that came out in the in the
discussion yesterday as Peter was
mentioning that the point about non
contextuality or the realist point of
view is that you know the trees in the
quad even if we don't look at it so
everything has a well-defined value
whether we're whether we're measuring it
or not so this lambda has the obligation
to assign a definite value to all the
variables so we know it assigns these
values to these two but what is it a
sign for example to the variable B -
well there are only two things that
could assign 0 or 1 but if it designed
this one then this would also be a
possible joint outcome and this entry
here tells us that it isn't so therefore
we must as we must conclude that the
only thing it can assign to B 2 is 1 and
now we can play the same game again I
mean now we're now that we know that B 2
gets assigned 1 we can ask what a 2 gets
assigned and again there are two
possibilities 0 or 1 but if it was
assigned 1 then this would be a possible
outcome and this thing tells us that it
isn't so that possibility is eliminated
and the only remaining possibility is
that a 2 gets assigned 0 so now we have
a complete specification of what lambda
would have to be however there is still
a constraint that we haven't considered
and that constrain and you can see if
lambda assigned these these
possibilities and in particular the
outcome 0 0 for a 2 and B 1 would have
to be possible lambda is in the support
of this distribution sitting in the
classical source but we see that this is
precluded so therefore we have to
conclude that there is no such lambda
and there can be no classical source and
we can see that essentially by the way
this is just a constraint satisfaction
problem even at this level just a sad
viability problem and we're we're saying
that there's no solution something sorry
those who don't cure yes yes right yes
absolutely absolutely yes pseudo qnp
completely there
so battleships there's been anyway so
right so yes but it has a but it's a
game that has in a sense of profound
consequence because it's telling us that
we have this information we can directly
see but we can't piece it together
globally and we can also think of it
geometrically I'm not going to go very
far down this road but that structure is
is really there just below the surface
and we'll expose a little bit more of it
shortly another way of putting this is
that there's a local section namely the
assignment to just the variables a1 and
b1 which cannot be extended to a global
section that's what's happening and
these constraints provide an obstruction
to extending the local section to a
global one and actually this together
with this connection with the constraint
satisfaction leads to some work with
where we focus on and Georg our table
where we've identified a sort of a non
trivial variant of the standard
constraint satisfaction paradigm
marriage robust constraint satisfaction
where the idea is can you find us not
just a solution in itself but the
solution which extend certain assigned
values to a subset of the variables and
you get a there's a non trivial variant
of the the the theory of
and delineating the tractability
boundary for that kind of constraint
satisfaction anyway those are kind of
side some offshoots of this kind of
argument anyway the conclusion we draw
once again is that Hardy models are
contextual they're paradoxes or at least
quasi paradoxes on the borders of
paradox in their sense they cannot be
explained by a classical source so now I
want to turn from that kind of logical
really way of looking at it to err to a
visual way which shows that there is
topological structure here which and we
can kind of see it so here is the hardy
table again instead of zeros and ones
I've written ticks and crosses they mean
the same thing a tick means is possible
across means is impossible in other
words probability greater than zero or
probability zero and what I want to do
now is draw a geometric diagram a bundle
diagram which will which will convey
exactly the information given by this
model so we start by just looking at the
variables that we're considering we
think of this as a kind of base space
where the space of the contexts so we
have a be a-prime b-prime the two
settings for alice and the two settings
for Bob and we introduce edges and the
idea is that there's an edge between two
variables if they can be measured
together so we can measure a with B or
with B Prime
Alice that this is the significance of
Alice and Bob being independent Alice
can make a choice Bob can make a choice
in any combination but we cannot measure
a together with a prime Alice has to
choose a spin direction or a angle for
polarization or whatever it is and can't
measure two different directions at the
same time with her particles so that's
the that's the very simple structure we
have here for the base base and now
we're going to have fibers and the fiber
simply give the possible values that
each variable can get which in this case
is just 0 or 1 in each
and now we're going to draw edges
between values in the fibers if they can
appear together as possible joint
outcomes so you see on the front face
here corresponding to this first row all
joint outcomes are possible so we have
four edges whereas on the a-prime be
face we have three possible joint
outcomes and one that's impossible so we
have three edges and similarly on this
face and this face so this is now a
bundle a little bundle diagram which
conveys exactly the information we have
from the table but now there's a lot of
information that's immediately
geometrically apparent firstly what does
local consistency mean in this in this
picture what it means is that if I start
with an edge one of these local sections
as it were there's always a way of
continuing if I'm if I'm on an edge and
I look at the the there's always some
edge abutting on the vertex at either
end of the edge and I start with why
does this correspond to local
consistency here we're just dealing not
where I mean we said yesterday that the
local consistency for probability
distributions meant having common
marginals here we're only speaking of
possibilities so what it means is to say
that if an outcome from Alice's point of
view as possible in a given context then
it should stay possible even if Bob were
to change which measurement he made
that's what that's what it means but you
see that
diagrammatically here what this means is
that for it well here let's say if the
outcome are zero is possible for Bob
when he makes the measurement be in the
context where Alice makes the
measurement a well it shouldn't depend
on which measurement Alice makes so
there should be some when Alice makes
the measurement a prime there should be
some outcome which is jointly possible
with this zero
which still makes it possible from Bob's
point of view and that's exactly saying
that we can continue the path so locally
a path can be always be continued and
that's the that's the sense in which
this data is locally consistent well
there's global consistency mean global
consistency means that we can we can
form a complete closed path that assigns
a unique value to every variable as it
were a univocal path where we get a
unique value assigned to each variable
and you can see that this diagram does
contain such a path which which assigns
a unique value to all of the four
variables but the sense in which this is
contextual is that there exists some
edge which cannot be extended to such a
univocal path and actually this is the
edge so this is the one that we saw from
from our here starting up zero zero on
this front face so we can try and extend
it so we know we can always locally
extend the path that's the local
consistency but when we come back we no
longer have the option to get back to
where we started so we don't form a
univocal path of course we could go the
other way whoops I'm going backwards
sorry so we could we could instead go
the other way and again we don't get
back to where we started so there is no
such path that extends that particular
section so that is the sense of which a
local section cannot be extended to a
global one okay so that is and that is a
form of contextual tea which as we've
seen is witnessed purely at the level of
possibilities or we could say purely at
a logical level so we call this possible
istic or logical contextuality could
there be something stronger and and the
answer is yes and this will take us
towards one of the main points we're
going to see in this in this lecture
which is that contextual tea is not an
all-or-nothing notion
either have it or you don't there's a
natural hierarchy that emerges actually
much more refined the mob will consider
here but will consider the main the main
points in this hierarchy and the
examples which have been extensively
discussed in the literature
indeed exemplify the different points in
this hierarchy so in particular here is
something which witnesses a stronger
form of contextual 'ti than the Hardy
paradox and indeed the the original Bell
table that we started off with and this
is this is a very interesting table
called the PR box it's interesting for
several reasons one one reason is that
although by now we may sort of have
difficulty distinguishing you know
science fact from science fiction
whereas the Bell table in the hardy
table are real things that can be
realized according to the predictions of
quantum mechanics and those loophole
free Bell tests were essentially
realizing some something pretty much
corresponding to the Bell table in
particular this as far as we know is
science fiction in the sense that this
goes beyond what can be achieved in
quantum mechanics so the reason I'm
using it as an example is because it's
it's simple and we can easily depict it
but also because it plays a very
important role in current research one
of the main reasons now one of the main
things people are trying to understand
in quantum information and foundations
now is not so much that we have
nonlocality and contextual 'ti this is
well-established confirmed of course by
the recent loophole free belt test but
everyone believed it anyway but is to
understand why nature as it seems gives
us this much namely the quantum
possibilities but no more and this is an
example of something more we can
actually prove we can actually prove
that this cannot be realized in quantum
mechanics because we can have although
there was a Bell inequality for the
which which we could think of as a
matter as a maximum inequality for
maximum success probability for winning
that
the xor game that we discussed at the
end of yesterday's lectures and there's
something called the turul sin
inequality which gives a maximum value
of success probability that can be
achieved for that game by any quantum
mechanical realization 0.83 I mean
remember the classical one was 0.75 this
one actually as you can see is a winning
strategy it has success probability 1
because the support you get is what's
being indicated here the support is
exactly corresponding to the winning
conditions for the XOR game those are
exactly there's nothing more so
therefore the whole weight of the
probability distributions is on the
winning winning positions so it achieves
the algebraic maximum of 4 for our
logical Bell inequality and it's a
winning strategy for the XOR game
there's another interesting point about
this PR box which will come back to a
little later which is that that although
I haven't written it well this is just
possibilities but actually given that we
have local for the local consistency
condition the no signaling condition
actually this is already sufficient to
determine the probabilities uniquely but
we'll come back to that point anyway
what I want to do now is to show you the
PR box from the same point of view of
the bundle diagram and this is very this
immediately hits the eye it's a kind of
discrete Mebius strip and what you can
see immediately and it's just with the
same the same conventions that we were
using before we have the base the fibers
and the edges and you can see that there
is no univocal path at all in this
diagram wherever you start from you're
never going to come back assigning
unique values to all the variables to
where you where you started out from
so this is what we call strong context
reality in fact now as I've said this PR
box is provable well if it's provably
not realizable in quantum mechanics and
as far as we have no reason to believe
it's realizable in nature because
everything tells us that what nature
realizes is what quantum mechanics
predicts but the same for extra strength
of contexture allottee is manifested in
quantum mechanics the thing is we need
to go to more parties in order to see it
which makes it harder to draw so there's
a very famous example in the literature
the green burger horn zhiling your state
which manifests strong contextuality so
just to yeah
so i will say this again but i mean just
to say that the idea is that the bell
table we really needed probabilities and
we couldn't make the argument just in
terms of possibilities with the hardy so
that's the weakest form of contexture
allottee with the hardy table we could
prove that that probabilistic form of
contextuality but we only needed
possibilities to do it and we have this
idea of a local section that could not
be extended to a global assignment to
all the variables and then with the
strongest form exemplified by the P R
box or in quantum mechanics by this
Greenberger horn zhiling your state we
have the strongest form where there is
no way of assigning values to all the
variables simultaneously which is
consistent with the model that's
extremely strong so provably for at
least with the limitations of two
measurements and two outcomes
the only strongly contextual models in
that in those dimensions are these of
the P R box and various relabeling z' of
it and none of those are quantum
realisable which shows that there's
something about that case that is not
really typical because as soon as you go
up to three parties each with two
measurements each with two outcomes you
get this gh said state and it is quantum
realizable and you do get
phenomenon and it's to do with being on
a vertex of a suitable polytope or you
know it's it we'll see more about that
later on okay so let me briefly say make
a connection with the classic discussion
of paradoxes in logic because surely if
we look at this PR box it's quite
evocative of various kinds of
paradoxical argument so here's so we
have the classic liar paradox but we
have more generally people discuss liar
cycles a chain of sentences each saying
the next is true and the last one saying
the first one is false and we can think
of it in terms of equations I mean
there's been a lot of recent discussion
of paradoxes in terms of boolean
equations which is quite a nice way of
discussing them so we can think of these
things if I've heard over the variables
they refer to and what we see is that
any N minus one of these equations is
consistent and the whole set is
inconsistent and the point is that the
life cycle of length four corresponds
exactly to the P R box so in that sense
the P R box is directly corresponding to
a very classic topic in them logic and
in fact the usual reasoning to derive a
contradiction from the liar corresponds
to the attempt to find the univocal path
in the bundle diagram so you know the
usual way you'd say is well assume that
one of the variables is true and then
you propagate the constraints locally
around and because of this fact that the
path doesn't bring you back to where you
started you end up with the opposite
value for the variable you started off
with and then you try the other one so
going the other way around then you end
up with the same result so it's really a
familiar theme in logic that has exactly
this topological way of looking at it so
there's much more that could be said on
this topological theme I mean firstly it
sort of all extends much more generally
we're going to look at the general
framework now but actually one can use
the formalism of sheaves and sheaf Co
homology to give witnesses for
contextual T it's a very nice story but
I'm not going
to go into it in these in these talks if
anyone's interested there we delighted
to discuss it and the ruie has also
worked on this Jayne Mansfield he'll be
he'll be here later in the program
okay I thought I'd mentioned one other
connection with logic which I feel
there's more possibly and it would be
again would be nice to explore it so
here is one of the classic theorems of
of logic closely related to the Craig
interpolation lemma when I gave Berkeley
logic colloquium a couple of years ago
linguish senior gentleman in the
audience at the end of lecture was
explaining to his neighbor the relation
between the Robinson consistency theorem
and the Craig interpolation lever and I
later learned that this was the 97 or
year-old William Craig serve as a nice
moment okay so here's the Robinson joint
consistency theorem so we have a couple
of theories if there's no sentence in
the intersection of the languages the
vocabularies of these theories where
they were where we have a contradiction
between the two theories then we can
form their Union that's the Robinson
joint consistency theorem in a fairly
standard formulation now that's a binary
result so a natural question it says
that two compatible theories could be
glued together in this binary case local
consistency implies global consistency
natural question what goes happens
beyond the binary case there's never
discussed in books as far as I know but
there's very good reason why it's not
discussed in books because it would be
false so here is a minimal counter
example just at the propositional level
three theories each pairwise locally
compatible but if you put all three
together they're inconsistent and this
actually correlates to a classic example
due to which is often known as the spec
spec triangle which is really
sort of just saying can I can I just
color the vertices of the triangle in
such a way that the it's really just the
basic case of the odd length cycle I
guess that none which was talking about
yesterday can I color this with two
colors in such a way that the the edges
are the adjacent vertices don't have the
same color so actually this would be the
simplest proof of what's known as the
coach and spec a theorem except that
again this triangle cannot be realized
in quantum mechanics
so instead Cochin inspector had to
construct an example with 117 vectors in
their famous 1965 paper and that number
of vectors in three space and and that
number has since been reduced to two 31
s they should yes yes actually you're
quite right and I I I forgot to correct
that yes thank you
right so yeah so again there's a sort of
connection there and I then so it seems
that some of the work that model
theorists have been doing recently on
amalgamation results some of it is quite
close to these kind of considerations
conditions under which amalgamation is
possible so had some nice discussions
with John Baldwin and Andres Villa
vetches last year they they pointed out
some references that had examples which
were surprisingly close to some of these
some of the things I've been discussing
here so again there may be interesting
things to explore the sort of
connections between amalgamation ideas
in current model theory and some of
these issues okay so now what I want to
do is we've really been discussing
examples but I want to set up some
general general framework in which we
can discuss these things and the nice
point is that all the concepts lift in a
fairly effortless way to this general
level which is general enough to cover
all the all the usual things that are
discussed in the in the in the
literature in in quantum information and
and possibly more things as well so the
first ingredient is the sort of
syntactic component as it were the
corresponding to the the vocabulary and
in in in a in the model Theory terms or
the schema in database terms is what we
call a measurement scenario so it's the
structure of the measurement the fact
that we had in our examples Alice and
Bob and they have various choices of
measurements and so on so the
ingredients are a set of variables that
label the measurements that can be
performed and we think of these are
variables that can be measured or
observed or evaluated and then a family
of sets of variables which are those
that could be measured together and
these these form the context
so we could be a little more general and
just say there's a relation between an
abstract set of contexts and a set of
variables but here we were just saying
that if two contexts have exactly the
same variables measurable in them then
we regard them as the same so we're just
identifying contexts with sets of
variables and we have a set of possible
outcomes or values for the variables so
as an example let's see how we can
reconstruct the Belle scenario Alice Bob
each with two measurements each
measurement with two outcomes in this
form so the set of variables is what we
expect the measurement contexts are
those measurements that can be made
together in other words any choice of
measurement by Alice together with any
choice of measurement by Bob so these we
have four contexts and the outcomes are
just 0 1 so this is in an obvious way
the covering that kind of example and
you can see that it would be quite easy
to extend this to any number of parties
any number of measurements for each
party and any number of outcomes for
each measurement so it's with all kinds
of multi-part I'd bell scenarios but it
deals with it deals with more things as
well I mean we just mentioned coach and
specter constructions
this is one of the often sort of by
Cabello and colleagues is one of the
simplest and standard ways of presenting
a coach inspector construction this is
with respect to four dimensions so in
that case 18 variables suffice but you
see it's so quite an intricate structure
so the context so this is the set X is
the set of 18 variables represent
labeled by these letters and the cover
that said the family of subsets is this
set of nine sets of variables each one
containing four variables the
significance of this combinatorial
structure is that we can label each of
these 18
letters by a unit vector in our for such
that each column forms an orthonormal
basis of our form and as far as the
combinatorial structure is concerned if
you look carefully you may notice that
each letter occurs in exactly two
contexts and between the fact that each
letter occurs in two contexts and that
there are nine contexts we can make a we
can make an argument to show the
appropriate form of strong context
reality for a construction based on this
so the main reason I'm showing this now
is to show that things can be as
combinatorially intricate I mean that
this covers a wealth of intricate
examples perhaps another point worth
making is that when we when we talk
about this family of subsets so it's a
hyper graph there are two things that
turn out to be useful in practice to do
and the certain amount of sort of moving
back and forth between them what we most
often do is foe is focus on the maximal
sets of compatible variables so you get
a family of the maximal contexts which
then none of which is included in any
other by definition so you get a but a
kind of irredundant representation that
way on the other hand if you have a set
of variables that's compatible you do
expect any subset also to be compatible
so the other way of looking at this is
that it's an abstract simplicial complex
and this is useful for developing the
topological point of view which i was
mentioning earlier so it's and become
and the other thing I should say is that
from for most purposes we take these
things to be finite because most of the
examples considered in quantum
information are naturally of that nature
and if you think about what you can
build in a lab what any protocol would
involve what any circuit would involve
the number of measurements and so on
would be finite so then you can pass
without loss of information between the
abstract simplicial complex point of
view and the just looking at the maximal
okay so that's the first ingredient the
kind of schema level and then the sort
of instance or structure level is what
we call the is what we call empirical
marvels so the terminology comes from a
paper by Adam Brandenburger and Allison
Janoski and it's a good name because one
of the important points about contextual
'ti is that it's in the data we make
these observations and then whether it's
contextual or not is structure that's
there in the data we don't have to
presuppose any underlying physical
theory this turns out to be a really
important point of view in contemporary
in sort of quantum cryptography where
people talk about device-independent
quantum cryptography where you don't
have to trust what the box that you've
been given is doing you don't even have
to believe that it's obeying the laws of
quantum mechanics and you can just rely
on the fact that typically Bell
inequalities are violated and that read
gives you a good enough guarantee that
in to secure your your cryptographic
properties so these tables can represent
wander Rises purely from observation on
the other hand of course quantum
mechanics as a predictive theory is
precisely an engine for generating a
family of these of these tables and
there's a more restrictive class which
are the ones that can be generated using
a classical source which is where we
started from anyway what is an empirical
model over a measurement scenario well
it's simply a family of probability
distributions over the one for each so
we have for each context the set of
possible outcomes for measuring the
variables in that context and then we
have a probability distribution over
those possible outcomes so let me just
mention this more explicitly a joint
outcome or event in a car
text is just an assignment of an outcome
to each variable in the context so it's
a member of this it's a function which
makes that it's a value assignment for
the variables in the context
and by assigning a probability
distribution over all such things we've
said we've given I mean that that's the
way we tabulate data so it's the general
form of a probability table so these
distributions are the rows of our
generalized probability tables so if we
if we anatomize table like the one we
saw earlier as we've already said the
measurement contexts of these the the
entries in the table refer to events
which are these assignments of values to
the variables values in the column to
the variables given in the row and each
row of the table specifies a probability
distribution so this is a special case
of the general definition but the
general definition can be over any hyper
graph so there's a bit of algebraic
structure which is really essential then
to working with these with these things
this algebraic structure I mean just
below the surface is really saying that
we have a we have a pre sheaf but I'm
going our D category fide these lectures
so I'm not going to speak explicitly of
that but we'll see that it's sort of
caches out in in in in the cases we're
interested in to familiar operations
like marginalization and projection so
but we have the idea that's very
familiar anyway that if you have
functions on subsets provided they're
compatible we can glue them together so
if the restrictions of these two
functions defined on the subsets U and V
and with a common codomain agree then
they can be glued to form a function on
the big subset so this is another
version of the exact the same kind of
situation that we saw with the Robinson
thing in many other situations so this
is really the local consistency
condition and the general form of this
local consistency condition is what
we'll call compatibility and what we
what the way we formalize this is by
saying just as we did for the functions
the familiar example here that the
distributions agree on overlaps so you
can only hope to glue functions together
if they they're consistent to start off
with meaning they agree on their overlap
the same should be true for
distributions so what does what does
restriction mean here so here's a
formula for the for the restriction of a
distribution but let me just say that we
can if we just write it like this so
we're going to a subset so we can think
of it just as a product and we're just
summing over the things that are not in
me in the factor that we're projecting
down to so we see that this operation of
restriction is just marginalization of a
probability distribution I'm only going
to be dealing with discrete
probabilities in these lectures but
I think everything does generalize after
Prakash's lectures we'll know how to do
that so so compatibility says that the
distributions on different contexts have
consistent marginals so it doesn't
matter which larger context you are when
you project down to a common sub part
you're going to get the same thing now
that's a natural Geo geometrically
natural condition a logically natural
condition but it's used but it's
important also to note that it relates
to an important physical principle known
as no signaling and it's this principle
which under writes despite all the
spooky action at a distance and all the
rest of it which nevertheless
underwrites the fact that quantum
mechanics is consistent with special
relativity with the causality structure
that we get from relativity so let's see
a particular case that makes this clear
suppose we're in a context II where
Alice can do measurement a Bob can do
measurement B there's another context
where Alice makes the same measurement
Bob is making the measurement B Prime
and Bob may be a long way away from
Alice but under relativistic constraints
Bob's choice of measurement should not
be able to affect the distribution Alice
observes on the outcomes from her
measurement of a or to put it the other
way around if Alice were able to observe
different different frequencies
different probabilities on her outcomes
of her local measurement if it did make
a difference she'd be able to infer
something about Wahb what Bob did even
though there was no time for information
about what he chose to do to propagate
through to Alice that would violate
relativistic causality now to the
constraint of ensures that that doesn't
happen is by saying that the
distribution on a as viewed as a subset
of a be marginalizing from the
distribution over a B to the
distribution on a should be the same as
what we get by marginalizing them from
the context a B Prime
so whether we marginalize from the
district
the context II or the context c-prime we
get the same thing and this condition is
directly generalized by compatibility so
here is here is our general
compatibility condition for arbitrary
shapes of contexts and arbitrary
intersections and this general form if
we interpret things suitably is
satisfied by quantum systems if
compatibility means computed commuting
observables then it's always satisfied
by quantum mechanics so this is a nice
coincidence of the geometric notion of
compatibility agreeing on the overlap
with this physical principle of no
signaling it's perhaps useful to really
spell out no signaling in the basic
Alice Bob case so it comes down to a
bunch of equations so I just label with
letters all the all the entries in such
a table and to say that we have
consistent marginals is just to say that
for example the probability for Alice
getting outcome 0 between the two
contexts where she can do the
measurement a should be the same whether
we're in this context so the outcome 0
is C plus E or whether it's in this
context so the the the probabilities for
these outcomes are k plus M so saying
that those two marginals coincide is
exactly saying that this equation holds
and there's a similar bunch of equations
for all the other cases where you fix a
measurement and look at the marginals
now if we if we relate that you can
check that these conditions are
satisfied by the bail table and if we if
we were to go back to the PR box
remember the PR box has entries 1 0 0 1
for the first 3 rows and then 0 1 1 0
for the last row so really you can see
for example that in the PR box see the e
is 0 and the M is 0 so it so the first
equation is telling us that this entry
equals that and if you play through all
the equations in the PR box it's telling
you that all the values have to be the
same so that directly proves that the PR
box the support of the PR box given that
it satisfies no signaling uniquely
determines the probability distributions
and in fact there have to be the uniform
distribution on every row and this is a
general a general fact about these
extremal cases of strong contextual
allottee ok so having set up this
general framework we can now define what
contextual leti means in general so we
have an empirical model on a measurement
scenario and we say that it's non
contextual there is a classical
explanation if there is a distribution
on all the variables which marginalizes
to give us back the observed
probabilities for every context which is
in geometric terms is saying we can glue
all the local information together into
a global consistent description from
which all the local directly observable
information can be recovered and we call
such a thing a global section because of
this geometric way of looking at it so
that's if such a thing does exist which
is really saying there's a classical
source there's a consistent description
of all the variables independently of
which ones we actually measure which is
consistent with everything that we
observe then the model is non can
textual and if no such section exists
the empirical model is contextual and
the import of Bell's Theorem and similar
results is that their empirical models
arising from quantum mechanics which are
indeed contextual and just to recap now
at the general level there's well
there's various class interesting
classes of empirical models that arise
of a particularly important one of
course from our point of view is those
empirical models which are quantum
realisable that is we can find quantum
states and local observables which
generate exactly the family of
distributions and I should say that that
well in the next lecture we'll look just
enough into the formalism of quantum
mechanics to see how that formalism
generates these kind of tables and you
can actually compute them for given
States and observables it turns out that
all quantum realizable models are
compatible and and it's the general form
of this principle of no signaling
however there are compatible no
signaling empirical models which are not
quantum realizable and the P R box is
the example we have so far of that and
so we get these this natural
stratification into a strict hierarchy
of three classes the non contextual
models those for which there is a
classical source those generated by
quantum mechanics and the broad class of
no signaling models still compatible
with relativity but containing things
that as far as we know are not
physically realizable well there's a
very natural question why aren't these
extra no signaling models physically
realizable why does nature select the
quantum set and no more and there's been
a lot of attempts to find is implausible
principles that would hit exactly the
quantum set reconstruction theorems of
various kinds and I think it's fair to
say that that nobody feels the last word
is by any means been said on that
subject I'm gonna do that in the next
lecture yes I haven't done that
but I will do in the next lecture yes
but as I say the the sort of general
idea is you know in in quantum mechanics
ordinary quantum mechanics you can say
well the state is of the on a given
dimension of system it's a it's a vector
or maybe a density matrix on a Hilbert
space and an observable is another kind
of operator and there's a formula the
born rule for generating the probability
so we'll see that exactly in the next
lecture but there isn't there isn't
anything that avoids that machinery in
describe and actually the issue of
describing this class is a very subtle
one and something I'm going to talk
about the next lecture is a very salient
open problem which is whether this class
in fixed finite dimensions is decidable
if you can given a table you can tell if
it is in this class for a fixed finite
dimensions even very small dimensions
that is an open question which seems to
be at least quite related to some deep
open problems which is perhaps a deep
open problem in itself ok so the P R Box
as we've already said satisfies no
signaling but is not quantum realizable
so we can get a natural geometric
picture I mean let me just bring will so
be seeing more of this later but we can
lay out a table as a vector in a high
dimensional real table a real vector
space it's a family of probability
distributions so each such thing can in
there on a finite set so each such thing
can be laid out as a vector of
non-negative reals and we can just
concatenate them all and we get we get a
we get a vector in this high dimensional
space so in a bail scenario with n
parties came measurements and L outcomes
this is the dimension and of course
empirical models are closed under convex
combination under probabilistic mixing
so these form a convex set and in fact
they form a polytope
the fact that they're well so so
actually let's let's be a little more
precise here the non can I mean we'll
see more about this in a later lecture
but the the set of non contextual models
form a polytope and the bell
inequalities precisely are the
inequalities that define that polytope
they're no signaling models well we
wrote down a bunch of equations in a
particular case and you can generalize
that for any scenario and you can get a
system of linear constraints which picks
out the no signaling models so than
those of the the no signaling models
including the PR box for any given
measurement scenario form a polytope and
of course they're strictly includes the
non contextual models and strongly
contextual models well they'll sit
either on vertices of the polytope or at
least on a face that only contains
strongly contextual models sitting in
between these two polytopes is this
complicated subtle set of quantum
correlations which is a convex and
closed set but not a polytope and the
question is is it a decidable set as we
were saying and we'll discuss that
tomorrow and I think this picture is
related to what perhaps to Simone as
onion which you'll talk about tomorrow
ok and then as I say the key question is
to find compelling principles to explain
why nature picks out the quantum set and
that project is still an ongoing one in
the in the community
so right so to finish up so let's let's
just put the definition of the hierarchy
of notions of contextual 'ti in this
general framework so given an empirical
model we have the idea of the support of
the model so it's that all those all
those assignments of variables over each
context which receives a nonzero
probability according to the
distribution for that context so on each
context we get a set of assignments
which are regarded as possible the
things that we get an entry one in our
support tables or a tick and if and by
us and there's well there's a sort of we
can descend from probability
distributions to supports in a
consistent fashion in such a way that if
the empirical model is compatible so is
the support so you see that for the
support to be compatible is just to say
that the set of that they have
consistent marginals in the sense that
if you just look at the assignments over
one context that are regarded as
possible and then you project down to a
smaller context you're going to get the
same set as if you project down from
another context so it's a projection
consistency condition which I think
would be familiar in database theory
you're just saying the projections onto
a given set of variables is going to be
the same whichever table you start with
that contains all the variables so the
support automatically satisfies no
signaling at the level of possibilities
right now in in these terms we can say
that a global assignment an assignment
to all the variables simultaneously the
sort of thing we were looking for
diagrammatically with the idea of a
universal path is consistent with the
support of the model if at every context
its restriction or projection down to
that context is in the support of the
model at that context and we say that
empirical model is logically contextual
and this is the general notion
corresponding to the hardy type paradox
if some possible joint outcome is not
accounted for by any global assignment
in other words we cannot extend the
local section to a global one which is
consistent with the support so the
failure to find this extension to a
global assignment is what we call
logical contextual attea notice there's
an existential quantifier if for some
local section there's no extension to a
to a global one and it's saying then
that the support of the model cannot be
covered by the consistent global
assignments and on the other hand it's
strongly contextual if no local section
it can be extended to a global one if
which is to say the support is not
consistent with any global section at
all so it's clearly a much stronger
condition and obviously strong
contextuality implies logical contextual
ality and in fact we get a hierarchy
strong contextual 'ti implies logical
contextuality which implies
probabilistic contextual T the bell
model which we started with is at the
lowest rung of this hierarchy it's
contextual or probabilistically
contextual but not logically contextual
its support is pretty full so you can
always extend local assignments with
global assignments as far as the support
is concerned but it's the probabilities
that form the obstruction to having a
global section the Hardy model is
logically contextual but as we saw not
strongly contextual it does contain some
it is consistent with some global
assignment and the PR box and then
quantum examples such as the gh said
stage is strongly contextual so we get
this strict hierarchy and in fact we can
witness the top level in quantum
mechanics with the gh said state with
any number of parties greater than or
equal to three and various other
examples so in terms of well know we're
widely discussed examples in the
literature they turn out to exemplify
the different levels of this hierarchy
okay so let me just finish up if I can
take a minute
by just mentioning that result in a
question it might be a nice place to
stop so we can lift this hierarchy which
is for models now models as arising from
quantum mechanics come from two
ingredients which we need to discuss
more fully the quantum states and the
quantum measurements and then you put
them together and get predicted
probabilities for the outcomes of the
measurements on the states but we can
actually lift this to give a way of
classifying quantum states in terms of
their degree of contextual T so you can
say that the state is strongly
contextual if for some choice of local
observables for each party the resulting
model is strong is is has this property
and simply for logical contextual ality
so what we're asking for is characterize
the multi part ID states the end qubit
States in terms of their maximum degree
of contextual T so that's the that's the
general form of question so we have a
result in this direction
paper which should be found on the
archive with common constant in the
Machine ganging which shows that the
Hardy paradox which we might think was a
very delicate thing that needed to be a
very special contrivance with a sort of
some delicate choice of state actually
this is not the case with one
exceptional class bizarrely again
showing that the the sort of bipartite
case
is a bit special the the exceptional
class curiously other maximally
entangled bipartite states but for any
other end qubit entangled state which is
not just a product of these these
exceptions and single qubit states that
we can find local observables which
witness a hearty paradox and actually
the proof is constructive and provides
an algorithm which given an N qubit
entangled state construct s-- actually
just n plus two local observables
leading to a logically contextual model
and the the algorithm is fairly simple
but the proof that it works is is quite
is quite non-trivial and this leads to a
question which is open and I think would
would be very interesting to get an
answer to which is to to answer the
question for which quantum states can we
find local observables which give rise
to a strongly contextual empirical model
I think that's quite a challenging
problem as I've tried to motivate it
makes good sense in in an in a logical
sense but of course it does
go into the issue of quantum
representation one can also ask for
which observables can you find States
and sort of dual eyes the question and
there are some results in those
directions there are actually several
directions that one can go in but I
think this this question in particular
it would be very nice to find an answer
to so if anyone has any any thoughts on
the lateral or indeed anything else that
ever isn't in this lecture I'd be very
happy to discuss them so I'll finish
there thanks
questions now we have a right
as I say if anyone wants to know about
the connections with the topology and
sheaves and so on then please do ask me
I'm not planning to cover them in the in
the lectures here